là ces notes logement en fait on occupe
ce logement légalement depuis un mois
dit donc il les avait baptisés les lieux
le jardin partagé est occupé de l'avenue
de langres des militants réveillé par
les forces de l'ordre vers 6h des
tractopelles pénètre sur cette parcelle
les engins retourne le terrain et
détruisent une partie des plantations
ils ont rasé absolument tout le jardin
collectif
ils ont tout cassé on as peut-être
encore dix pieds darricau et quelques
salades mais sinon tout ce qui était
tomates courges melons courgettes
tout a été ravagée on avait aussi pris
soin de maintenir des espaces de friches
pour les abeilles et la biodiversité qui
était en très grand nombre dans tous les
rentiers et là tout a été défriché
depuis mi juin
un collectif de militants s'est
approprié cet espace prévu pour la
construction d'un immeuble
les occupants ont défriché le terrain
pour en faire un jardin collectif est un
lieu de rencontre n'a pas l'objectif
n'ont pu dire rester notre objectif
c'est pas 2 c'est pas de nous installer
là on cherche pas un logement ce qu'on
veut c'est que les gens du quartier
s'emparent de ce projet voit que ça peut
être un lieu de sociabilité des changes
de partage
après trois heures d'occupation les
engins de travaux rebrousser chemin sous
les applaudissements des militants et de
certains riverains venus apporter leur
soutien
c'est dommage on vit dans un monde
malheureusement avec beaucoup trop de
violence
moi je rapporte ça la violence parce
qu'ils ne font pas de mal ils veulent
pas de béton quelque part ils n'ont pas
tort que ce soit 10 janv les autres
villes il ya beaucoup de béton partout
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont pris
le terrain ils ont fait des petits
charguia pour les habitants dakota est
propriétaire du terrain
la mairie maintient son projet qui n'a
fait l'objet d'aucun recours